it was a moment 150 years ago that
forever changed the nation a golden
ceremony spike driven into the tracks at
promontory summit in Utah joining the
Union Pacific with the Central Pacific
Railroad's now America had a
transcontinental route across the West
and as Barry Peterson reports there is
still a way to experience the romance of
the rails on a journey back in time this
was once the sound and fury of the West
a wilderness conquered steam and coal
and in this remote part of Colorado and
New Mexico on the Cumbres and Toltec
Scenic Railroad steam and coal will take
you to the West Was so this really
settled for the West they just settled
the West and do we see what it's like
today we will see the world as it
existed 140 years ago John Bush is
president and general manager no paved
roads no power lines and no parking lots
this is essentially a time capsule 64
miles of 1880 and once you get out of
town it is the authentic West not the
Hollywood West but the real West the way
it actually was cell phones smart phones
none of that stuff works as soon as you
get out of town its roots go deep built
to bring prospectors for the silver and
gold rush of the late 1800
[Music]
taken over in 1970 by people who wanted
not just to preserve it but to give
others a railroad experience from a
century gone by all four tickets ranging
from a hundred to two hundred dollars
for a six-hour trip people begin to slow
down you know we see the West here at 12
miles an hour
and for a long time retired chef Chris
Carlton Corpus Christi Texas saw much
more than just scenery when you look out
across this countryside do you think you
would ever want it to come across this
thing on a horse or a wagon it gives you
a really thoughtful mind of how those
people made those decisions what made
them come this way and obviously endure
what is just
dangerous in its time the steam engine
was the peak of high-tech the 1800s
version of 747 or the Space Shuttle you
look at a computer now and well some
wires go in or some signals go in and
some stuff comes out but you can't tell
how it works inside here if you look at
a steam locomotive oh this rod has
hooked to that piston and when that
moves then this turns when that turns
then this does that and you can walk
yourself through it those who drive them
say they have the rhythm and the soul of
a living thing for 24 years
Carlos Lamas has been an engineer the
job
millions of children dreamed of doing
hundreds of people wish they could do
this we do it on a regular basis it
really is the coolest thing on the
planet
it really is and when you make this
thing move you must feel like you're
king of the world
yes I do I believe I'm king of the world
and the railroad is also an economic
engine for the area pouring 15 million
dollars a year into the local rural
economy with jobs on the train fixing
the rails and refurbishing old cars for
a new career back in service it was
watching trains and steam engines as a
child that captivated John Bush for life
and made him jump at the chance of
taking over here seven years ago and how
many of us can say this when I first
started doing this I actually wanted to
do it enough that I finally got to where
I found it boring that never happened
that never happened it is still
fascinating and it for me it's great
I've literally gotten to get paid to do
what I wanted to do
[Music]
it is said that the wail of a train
whistle and trigger along for a journey
for an adventure and here for a steam
Goliath taking us places we never
dreamed we would see for CBS this
morning the Saturday Mary Peterson
riding the rails across the West
beautiful ah beautifully shot